اذا عاده الاضواء بكثافه لشبه جزيره القرم
ضمن مجريات الحرب في اوكرانيا وهذا يعيد
للواجهه الاهميه الاستراتيجيه لهذه
المنطقه لاسيما بالنسبه لروسيا التي
تعتبرها بوابتها نحو المياه الدافئه في
البحر الاسود ومنفذها باتجاه مضيقي
البوسفور والدردنيل وصولا للبحر المتوسط
تبلغ مساحه شبه جزيره القرم 27 الف كيلو
متر مربع ولها اهميه جيوسياسيه بالغه حيث
يقع بها مقر قياده اصول البحر الاسود
الروسي ويسمح موقعها للصواريخ الروسيه
بتغطيه الجزء الشرقي بالاوروبا كاملا
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي للقرم يتجاوز
اربعه مليارات دولار سنويا وتشكل الخدمات
فيه 60% والزراعه عشره بالمئه بينما تحتل
الصناعه
16% كما تتوقع تقديراتنا يبلغ انتاجها
السنوي من النفط سبعه ملايين طن